cela fait deux mois maintenant que dix
premiers centres de vaccination ont vu
le jour dans les yvelines sur décision
du préfet du département
toute l'organisation logistique
matérielle et humaine repose sur les
communes et les collectivités
territoriales
même si l'état prend en charge la
logistique des dos ce ne sont plus les
préfectures qui gère l'organisation des
centres de vaccination sur les
territoires comme cela a pu être le cas
au moment de la crise h1n1
il ya aussi le fait qu'il ya une
décentralisation et donc c'est aussi à
nous de prendre nos responsabilités et
d'être là pour organiser les fabre a
davantage suis reposé vers ceux qui ont
lu les ressources matérielles elles
mêmes une organisation importante pour
les mairies qui doivent gérer les listes
d'attentes en fonction des doses
disponibles
l'agglomération de versailles grand parc
compte 270 mille habitants mille
personnes sont sur liste d'attenté pour
la seule ville de versailles
je vous avouerai que c'est ça un peu
complexifier les choses mais parce qu'il
ya deux entrées possibles donc par
l'application ou quand le site octo
libre et puis par des listes d'attentes
qui sont constituées dans les mairies
autre difficulté pour les communes
trouver du personnel soignant
disponibles qui sont déjà eux mêmes
submergé par les différentes vagues en
débit donc c'est à nous d'organiser cet
encadrement sanitaire un encadrement
administratif avec nos personnels de la
ligue
et puis on n'y a rejoint également du
bénévolat et c'est grâce à toutes ces
forces volontaire que les mairies
peuvent réagir rapidement
comme lors du week-end du 6 et 7 mars ou
cinq mille doses supplémentaires ont été
distribués dans les différents centres
ça voulait dire quand quelques heures et
je dis bien en quelques heures il
fallait prendre la décision d'ouvrir le
vélodrome durant le week end ce qui
n'était pas le cas jusqu'à présent
mais c'est pas tout de l'ouvrir ça veut
dire qu'il faut des médecins il faut des
infirmières et infirmiers quatre
nouveaux centres ont ouvert il ya deux
semaines dans les yvelines à
saint-cyr-l'ecole sartrouville crêpière
et les mais nul